MICHEL DEGRAFF: Yes, I do
think that the Black Matters
course has taken new urgency
in this current climate.
If we think, for example, of
the most recent elections,
the campaigns that we all
heard on TV, on the radio,
in the newspapers, it's
clear that identity politics
played a key role.
So if you think of the various
claims about immigrants,
about Muslims, about race,
about blacks, identity politics,
I think, was a major
focus of the campaign.
And I think the students
themselves, when I look at--
when we started, I gave out
the questionnaires asking them
why they took the course, what
drove them to Black Matters.
And many of them actually
assume that the course
is called Black Matters because
of the Black Lives Matter
movement.
But in fact, that course
started 10 years ago,
before there was a Black
Lives Matter movement.
But within themselves,
they came to the course
wanting to address current
political issues, including
issues of race, of identity, of
migration, of religious hatred.
So definitely, there was a sense
of urgency coming especially
from the students'
perspective themselves.
They wanted to
discuss these issues
and get a better understanding
of how to process,
but also how to counter
some of these claims
about identity, race,
religion, migration, etc.
So as I was thinking about
the syllabus and the course
description, I couldn't
help but thinking
about the slogan of building
walls to protect, say, the US.
And as I was picking texts
and choosing guest speakers,
I realized that it was important
to create a new narrative
around this issue of
walls, because I think
that our humanity is in reach
when we can build bridges
instead of brick walls.
So for me, the course-- and also
for some of my guest speakers--
it was important to
create a new narrative
around the concept of
building bridges that indeed
will make this world
great, not just the US,
but the world great.